the official story is the Master Chief
is dead
use Spartan Locke are the unofficial
story your mission is all is not as it
seems the latest news out of halo 5
guardians tells us that Master Chief is
not dead as can would have you believe
instead the savior of the galaxy has
disappeared and it would seem he's not
taking calls
but of course this isn't the first time
that the chief has hopped the fence and
gone off radar for what the UNSC
believed to be the pinnacle of
super-soldier development he's had more
than his fair share of black marks for
disobeying orders I am ordering you to
surrender today I know sir not a single
person can deny Master Chief's
contribution to the galaxy stopping the
Covenant from firing the halo array
literally saved the lives of everyone
humanity has put their complete faith
and trust in this man a man we know
almost nothing about but this time
something is different and a bigger
question looms over simply where he's
gone why would the UNSC who've upheld
Master Chief as a hero
lie about his death the Office of Naval
Intelligence has a directive stating
that Spartans can only be listed as
wounded or missing in action not only
have they said that Spartan 1 1 7 is K
IA but they've also lied about it this
can only lead us to one conclusion
Master Chief for some reason has
actively and knowingly betrayed the UNSC
in a bid to protect public morale they
would have had no choice but to kill the
chief in spirit than risk the legacy of
humanity Savior
this time he doesn't want to be found it
would seem the Master Chief has gone
rogue
now team Osiris led by Spartan Locke has
been specifically sent by UNSC to hunt
them down so what do we know what could
have possibly triggered chief to vanish
so suddenly secretly that's not the
official job title but it's close enough
hello I'm not so much hunting a spark as
I'm hunting the spark
we're looking at a soldier who joined
the Spartan program at age six after 40
years in the military having faced the
most unimaginable threats in the galaxy
having saved all sentient life multiple
times and having lost his only friend
and Guardian AI Cortana has this soldier
cracked under the weight of
responsibility as the UNSC simply asked
too much of Master Chief if he has been
broken what could a man of his strength
and experience unleash back upon
humanity but a question remains on
exactly that who he is
everyone agrees that his origins are
sketchy at best john-117 would have
undergone heavy biological and
mechanical augmentations as a child in a
bid to create the ultimate soldier is it
possible then that the UNSC has simply
lost control of a lap dog they thought
they had tamed who are you I am what
remained of the four but in Master
Chief's encounter with the forerunner
known as the librarian we find out that
he was engineered as a seed planted back
into humanity after the halo array was
originally fired to defeat the flood his
evolution had been deliberately
accelerated making him invulnerable to
the composer a device used by the
forerunner Didact
to digitize living beings into
Prometheans
clearly the forerunners the shepherds of
the galaxy and builders of the halo
array have greater plans for Master
Chief if they planted him into
civilization do they also have control
over him
the librarian appears to want to further
humanity but who knows if she can be
trusted
you are the combination life and times
of planning this predetermined greater
purpose rings all sorts of religious
bells - skipping past the references of
the covenant the planet Requiem and the
ark Master Chief's named John 1:17 is
itself a Bible reference it speaks of
the law being delivered by Moses but the
truth being delivered by Jesus are we
supposed to infer that the UNSC has set
the law but it's the chief who will
deliver the truth is he destined on a
path to sacrifice himself to save
humanity then we come to the matter of
the embassy attack on Biko we now know
that master chief attempted to rescue
the earth ambassador Richard saqib Oh
from the terrorists Sapien sunrise after
the UNSC refused it didn't work out
perfectly as the key bows mortally
wounded body was left in a field for the
UNSC to collect for better or worse
chief is found once again taking matters
into his own hands but in a way earth
already has an ambassador in Master
Chief
as a hailed hero he acts on behalf of
humanity with humanity's full supports
so is he power-hungry
is the a minion of the foreigners is he
a malfunctioning Augmented tool or is he
just a broken old soldier soldiers
aren't machines
we're just people
she said that to be once
by being a machine
you
you